so I just had a phone call from a couple
of girls I've been like are you
charlieissocoollike and I was like yeah
I'm charlie is so cool like how did you
get my home phone number
apparently they live like 10 minutes
away from me and they were having a
competition with their friends to see
who would be the first person to have a
conversation with a famous youtuber and
basically they look through the phone
book and just cooled every single house
under the name McDonald until they found
me I mean they seem like quite nice
girls you know they seem quite normal
and not stalkerish or anything but it
was just just weird
I actually just tried calling them back
but they withheld their number so
there's nothing I can do I'm never gonna
know who these people are ever oh oh
this is so odd if anyone finds my home
phone number please don't call me I have
emails set up for this kind of thing you
know if you want to talk to me send me
an email
please don't phone up my house and be
like are you charlie is so cool like
because this is just completely messed
with my mind okay
okay my mind has been set a little bit
more at ease now because they just sent
me an email saying don't worry we're not
gonna leak your number on the Internet
their names are Alison Vicky so Alison
Vicky congratulations on the ten pounds
that you want on that bet you probably
should have made a bet about whether or
not Charlie is so cool like we make a
video about you I thought you could have
one a bit more money out of that I'd
also like to congratulate you on the
mental harm you have now caused me oh
you're being well-known on the internet
is not easy